ça va en ce moment ouais nous ça va
c'est les biscuits c'est difficile
surtout pour le frais
face à Aurore berger la ministre des
Solidarités la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines partage c'est
difficulté deux épiceries sociales
maraude deux fois par semaine l'unité
locale a doublé sa capacité d'accueil on
a plus de difficultés sociales d'avoir
du bénévolat que d'avoir des problèmes
financiers il est évident que nos vu
qu'on achète une partie des produits
qu'on met à disposition à l'épicerie il
est évident que les coûts augmentent
mais pour l'instant financièrement on
est encore dans les rails on peut on
s'en sort mais je vais dire
l'aide que va donner le gouvernement et
aux trois grandes associations
caritatives françaises on va en avoir un
petit morceau et ça va nous ça va nous
faire du bien quand même le 5 septembre
dernier le ministère des solidarités des
familles annoncées le déblocage 156
millions d'euros pour les associations
d'aide alimentaire les associations
caritatives notamment les associations
du don alimentaire vous savez qu'elles
sont très sollicitées parce que
malheureusement on a des Français qui
ont besoin d'avoir recours à l'aide
alimentaire et tout simplement pouvoir
manger des repas qui sont des repas
sains des repas équilibrés c'est aussi
garder sa santé c'est une clé en fait
tout simplement pour pouvoir rebondir
ensuite pour reprendre confiance en soi
un soutien pour les associations d'aide
alimentaire mais d'autres associations
tirent la sonnette d'alarme sur une
problématique que beaucoup partagent le
manque de subventions pour financer un
peu plus les actions que nous menons
parce que par exemple nous avons tout un
travail aussi sur la citoyenneté on
essaye de sortir les personnes qui sont
chez nous de leur secteur quoi parce que
on s'est aperçu que ce sont des gens qui
ne bougent jamais qui ne vont pas au
théâtre qui ne vont pas au cinéma qui ne
qui ne vont jamais visiter quelque chose
et nous on les emmène au musée on les
emmène au théâtre on les emmène au
spectacle au cinéma etc outre l'aspect
financier les associations soulèvent la
difficulté à trouver des bénévoles selon
une étude de 2022 elle comptait 15% de
bénévoles de moins qu'en 2019